all right
see I had a control right
should I be scared send help call the
police
happy Monday everybody you know we talk
a lot about the woke and why not they're
fun to talk about they're so ugly
[Laughter]
in a way it's fun to talk about any
clueless group whether they're extreme
vegans or Maroon 5 or Fox and Friends
hosts
excuse me
I'm on tonight
also the work are just fun to watch
pregnant person or person that could
become pregnant and you provide a
definition for the word woman I can't
you can't not in this context
what you cannot do is to label a person
illegal there is no such thing as an
illegal human I am Kamala Harris my
pronouns are she and her I am a woman
sitting at the table wearing a blue suit
but there's more than one kind of woke
if you defied woke it's someone who's
awake perhaps with an angrier
consciousness of course they have to
share this newfound Rage with everyone
as they seek to infect every crevice of
society with their unbridled ignorance
the woke had a few good years now to
undo Society attacking traditional
family structure societal Safety and
Security but like Jamie lissau at his
own home
[Laughter]
it's no longer welcome
and it's created a rebound woke which
has come in the shape of something
monstrous powerful and really scary some
people do call it a birthing person but
we still call them mom
introducing mom's gone wild
you fighting for their
favorite anti-woke Warriors are here
like moms fighting leftist school boards
moms fighting for fair Sports moms
fighting to keep drag queens out of the
library and moms fighting to keep boys
out of the girls bathroom plus tons of
hot tennis moms Hot Yoga moms and hot
construction worker moms we even have
hot grandmas it's the hot moms hot mobs
wow that's awesome it's mom's going wild
and if you call now we'll throw in the
sexiest hot tub dance
[Applause]
other things I did for money
but true moms are back belligerent and
buzzed on watermelon margaritas but
first let's look how the awoke first
targeted them first they said men can
get pregnant that's total BS I've tried
many times I don't have the
I just don't have the hips for it
the woke also maintained men can have
periods which is baloney too the closest
I've come to having a period is spilling
marinara on my khakis
they also say men can compete against
your daughters in sports but this
apparently only goes One Way trans women
can swim and wrestle but good luck
seeing trans men in the NBA
follow the money in the trans experiment
dries up like my elbows in January
meanwhile
look meanwhile look at the biological
man who barged into women's sports and
women's locker rooms that's masculinity
more toxic than anything kamala's
husband can point to
[Laughter]
and and he lives with a cackling
chemical spill
foreign
they believe the relationship between
mother and child can be intruded upon by
a stranger and not even one in a van
it's one with an agenda under the guise
of right to privacy meaning you have no
idea that a teacher fresh out of college
who's soaked in oppression lingo and
hair dye can imprint his hers them theys
on your kids and parents shall not be
informed right to privacy is code for
don't tell Mom and Dad that for
Dodgeball we now throw
[Laughter]
actually they claim it takes a village
to raise your child and they're just the
village idiots to do it and so woke this
became a political mutation of
Munchausen by proxy where people
suffering from a manufactured delusion
transfer it onto children for attention
sympathy and now tenure so I am now
non-binary and you are too I believe the
planet is about to die and so shall you
I have more nose rings than a shower
curtain
so shall you I have more face piercings
than someone who tried to commit suicide
with buckshot
snorted and so will you it transfers a
mind rise in a mind of virus from one
infected person to another and the newly
infected has no immune system for it
because it is a child but there is an
effective booster for it it's called an
angry mom and it's perfect for fighting
the wokeness true moms might make you
cringe but that's what moms do but so do
third graders being forced to look at a
drag queen suspicious package so this
new woke are Republican moms independent
moms and over time more and more
Democrat moms and some of these women
God forbid have become Governors oh
our new education Freedom account allows
parents to enroll their kids in whatever
school is most appropriate for their
family and within three years it'll be
available to every family in Arkansas
so that's a governor but more
importantly a mom and she's governing
like a mom not a nanny
so
this new woke is this new woke more
appealing than the old woke well
obviously they're better looking but
also moms are not United or tricked by
the abstractions of pronouns and hate
speech it's all about practical concerns
concerning a struggle struggle for the
minds of their own children that's worth
waking up for and our moms never let
anybody sleep late and these moms won't
either so they're at the school board
meetings at protests at rallies they're
here to hand out snacks and kick ass
and they're fresh out of Trail Mix
[Applause]
if he has to hear one more divorced dad
joke he's gonna complain to his kids
every other weekend actor writer and
comedian Jamie Lisa
if you ask his family he's actually not
coming to work enough who said one
nation and the Brian kill me radio show
Brian kill me
and she's like a picket that's white has
good points but don't sit on her bucks
his contributor captive
[Applause]
ah calm down you crazy people
vivec welcome back to the show so what
do you got to what do you have to say to
like the parents out there where do you
stand on all this I'd say keep standing
up if you're a mom if you're a parent
it's your kids not the kids who belong
to the school it's actually pretty
simple
they used to say that math is racist
that was a popular thing in the woke
movement in schools you know math isn't
racist but you know what might be is not
teaching black kids how to do math which
is a big problem right
but you know if there's a mind virus I
think the lab leak for this virus
actually was the Federal Government it
was the Department of Education and not
a lot of people know this Greg but they
use the money they give to schools it's
not just the school boards that are bad
the money they use is like a handcuff
that forces these schools to adopt these
woke ideologies and that's why I've kept
it pretty simple if I'm president I'm
running for president I say I'm going to
shut down the Department of Education
because it doesn't actually need to
exist and I think so a lot of these woke
cancers start in the bad places you'd
expect actually in the federal
government so there's actually things we
can do about it that would be amazing
shut down this apartment
replace it with like a hot pretzel truck
that way they say what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do check this out
it's like a hot pretzel truck ah Jamie
in your life that would be amazing for
you because then you know you probably
don't eat well some
that's true
by the way how annoying all the woke
video I just got more and more annoyed
as those clips were being played I'm
sorry I will never say birthing people I
will you know what I mean yeah I will
continue to say people that won't sleep
with me
[Applause]
yeah but for real I got kids at kitchen
why did you just say Earth
yeah I shouldn't that umbrella could
have been wider
you're right but you should be able to
choose where your kids Goes to School
100 absolutely like we had to change my
kids school they were we had
teachers they were getting bullied and
we were homeschooling them
that's
amazing that's pretty funny
yeah I'm getting tired of like schools
in general I do homework with Mike my
kids in eighth grade they I feel like
more work can be done at this I feel
like all they do at school is just give
my kid work for me to do when he comes
home for real it's it's
do you know what I mean it's absolutely
exhausting all I found out doing math
was that I wouldn't graduate eighth
grade yeah getting harder because it's
like there's like x's and y's I don't
know any oh the only math I know for
sure is One X can equal losing 50 of
yours
[Music]
yeah
Brian at least he's not bitter I know he
doesn't seem angry that you remember
your family
I I have photos or like is there
something is there outside of this
building so which you never leave right
you have pictures on your desk so you
ask them questions you attacked me yeah
by the way the only thing I am very
scared of your audience yeah they are
they're pumped up and happy but almost
too happy I came to the side of it's UFC
or WWE yeah if I have to make a choice
what uh what's a problem for hosts at
Fox and Friends when they come on here
they're not used to being light right
oh they love you they love you they love
you no that they're women taking off
their tops right now
oh that's because it's so hot in here I
do it too I think what's happened uh the
only good thing out of the pandemic was
now the parents can know they cannot lay
back anymore I mean between the
curriculum that they're learning between
uh the things that kids are coming home
with we used to be worried that a kid
will come home in eighth grade and think
well uh global warming is real and it's
overrated and they Panic now we find out
about gender you're picking their gender
uh they're deciding whether or not
they're going to study they're deciding
well they're deciding that they know
more than their parents and I just think
the worst thing they've done is they've
gotten women moms involved and they're
not saying the Democratic Republicans
they're just saying they're angry and
they want it fixed so that's helps the
Glenn junkins of the world it helps the
Ron desantises the world it helps the
Vivek ramaswamis of the world
when they talk about when they talk
about school everybody's whole years
they're not going to say I want the
Democratic women or the Republican women
I like my answer as good as Jamie's and
almost as good as this remind everyone
when I say I remember when uh little uh
little Janet came home from school as it
was a junior in high school and she was
talking about how the teacher was
telling her about pronouns and she said
she wanted to be a they so I dumped her
[Laughter]
see that's what happens when Brian talks
I just think of things to say right and
it was worth it right I just thought of
saying that I didn't even do the math
cat
yeah how are you well I just love this
panel of moms you've assembled
a bunch of dudes and me
uh yeah I just don't see how it's
controversial to be like you know what
maybe you should have some say where
your kid goes to school uh anybody who
kind of wants to fight against that idea
is implicitly saying that they know for
a fact that it's a problem because some
schools are very bad and the only reason
they're allowed to be so bad is because
kids are forced to go to those schools
anyway I don't think the government
should have this much say I think that
it's ridiculous I think that family's
parents they know what's best for their
kids and I don't see how that's
foreign
that was a great block and we got more
blocks to come hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else